my favorite thing is when i do like a
television interview and the guy with
the microphone does this oh yeah he
knows my times yeah he'll move the mic
like no no i get this is good but you
know
but look
even now without him saying something
and that's what's amazing about your art
is he's not saying anything it's just so
expressive already well that's one of
the other things is the manipulation is
uh just being able to you know
i don't realize how hard it is until you
give it to somebody who doesn't know
what they're doing then it's like oh
yeah
yeah
because you're not doing anything yet
but you're doing so much you know i'm
watching him and he's got more character
right now than you like eyebrows our
work you know he's fine yes well it's
good to see you again howie and his uh i
don't know the young lady your exactly a
jacqueline when you see it it's his
daughter oh yeah like i care great
oh that's a nice dumly you got there on
the uh on your desk there howie it's a
horrible looking
it's me i uh you look better
[Laughter]
i look better than yeah you do you look
a lot better than your doll once the
characters are established the jokes
kind of write themselves out no
well no i mean you can go off and look
at him
he's got he's got paperwork but what's
funny is he takes out if you're just
listening to this so jeff has got some
material that he's written for today's
uh performance but he he takes out the
paper he's got the paper and he's
showing the paper
well see to the
happens on stage if there's something
when i do something like that when i
have to pull a piece of paper out on
stage i'll start looking at it and then
he'll look over and he'll
look good yeah
at first it's like oh that makes perfect
sense and it's like wait a minute you
want to do a couple of these
okay
donald's trump attorneys are really
feeling the fire lately but they will
not give in to attorney-client white
privilege
thank you can i keep that
thank you very much hold on just do this
one down here uh
i love that i got hold on uh
i'm stalling because he can't find it
uh come on where'd it go uh oh there's
oh yeah okay uh joe biden was asked what
he thinks of the canadian truckers he
said they're my favorite hockey team
thank you
thank you so much thank you
thank you yeah that's all you good uh
you're done two and out okay we'll do
one more all right
okay i gotta close how do you know that
wasn't a closer yeah because it's the
second one that could have been the
closure
i think it was supposed to be yeah
i haven't gone through this enough we
can re-edit this this podcast and we can
put that joke first
let's make the judgment after he does
this yeah okay uh
okay okay do the second to the last
second okay
i find myself watching events i never
would watch during the olympics i
watched women's figure skating russia
took gold usa took silver and north
korea's kim jong-un took the swedish
woman's team hostage
thank you so much
[Laughter]
[Music]
you